do you think
shorting is um can you speak at a high
level just for your own as a person
is it good for the world is it good for
markets
i do think that the two kinds of
shorting evil shorting
[Laughter]
and chill shorting okay evil shorting
is what melvin capital was doing um
and it's like you put a huge position
down you get all your buddies to also
short it
and you start making press and um and
trying to
bring this company down yeah um and i
don't think
in some cases there's you go out after
like fraudulent companies say this
company's a fraud
maybe that's okay like some but but this
they weren't even saying game stoppers
they're just saying it's a bad company
and we're gonna bring it to the ground
bring it to its knees
um a quant fund like
numerai we always have lots of positions
and we never have a position that's like
more than one percent
of our fund so we actually have
right now 250 shorts um i don't know
any of them except for one because
it was one of the meme stocks but um
yeah but it we shorting them
not to make them go we don't even want
them to go down necessarily yeah that
doesn't
sound a bit strange did i say that but
we just want them to
to not go up as much as our longs right
so by shorting a little bit
we can actually go along more in the
things we do believe in
so when we were going long in tesla we
could do it with more money than we had
because we would borrow from banks who
would lend us
money because we had longs and shorts
because we didn't have market exposure
we didn't have market risk
and so i think that's a good thing
because that means
um you know we can short the oil
companies and go along tesla and make
the future come forward faster
and i do think that's not a bad thing
you